nning David Kirkpatrick when you think
of Steve Case what do you think about
Wow well I think of my nice when i
worked at I'm Time Warner so you know I
think a lot about that deal I think of
having been on AOL I think of him having
kind of pioneered consumer use of the
Internet I mean we didn't call it the
internet then we called it a 0 L but
yeah I think of him as a major pioneer
and actually something of a friend who's
been involved in other tech me
conferences quite a few times here's an
informative chart we showed this earlier
let's do it again the green circle is
where Steve Case got out the green
circle is where crow Patrick loaded the
boat I tri-border hot thai border shares
so there here we are you know but I
talked about the facebook effect Steve
all I'm a huge fan of David I'm a fan of
Tom's through what is the effect forward
for all this technology were living
every both David's book and Facebook a
great example of what happened the
second way but once that first wave was
built and people were all connected to
the internet then the focus was building
on top of the internet Facebook didn't
exist at the beginning of the second way
of now one of the most valuable
influential companies in the world
arguably the most influential media
company even though they don't own
content because of the way they
distribute we just shows you what
happens with with disruption to come be
can come out of nowhere and be a global
giant we'll see other companies like
that come out of the third wave get
instead of focusing on social media apps
there's gonna be focusing on key parts
of our lives like how do we stay healthy
or how do our kids get get educated or
how do we manage energy or even how we
think about and consume food some big
parts of our lives big sectors of the
economy actually haven't been disrupted
that much in the first wave or the
second way but they will be in the third
way but it will require different
mindset a different playbook which is
why I finally decided to put pen to
paper and write a book see if it's
unclear to me what Facebook becomes in
5-10 years from now what kind of company
will it be at the moment they're very
quiz ative they have oculus they have
other parts they integrate it how big
will they become and how far-reaching
will they be well they've done a great
job in taking that initial idea initial
service and expanding it in new ways
even this weekend yesterday particularly
they launched a new initiative Facebook
live with a 24 hour a channel which is
reading a lot of attention but as you
mentioned they're not just focusing on
how do they evolve that platform
involved the Facebook brand but when
they've seen interesting new brands
coming up interesting disruptive cuppa
tea
whether it be an Instagram or whatsapp
or virtual reality with oculus they say
we want to be part of that future and
they jump into it through it through an
acquisition I think big companies in the
third wave will need to understand
what's happening with these
entrepreneurs and not just watch them
with skepticism but jump in and figure
out a way to partner with them or in
some cases by them JV jumping well I
wanted to I love talking about Facebook
but I wanted to make a comment about the
third wave that connected to facebook
and i think i love that steve is
focusing on this disruptive potential of
this next phase for all industries I
totally believe it but one way to think
about that is what a 0 L did and what
Facebook really did and it's one of the
reasons I wrote a book about Facebook is
it empowered the individual in a
fundamental way that really changes the
nature of economic landscape and the
third wave in a sense is all industries
having to adapt to a world where
consumers have a voice through live
video and all kinds of things that gives
them unprecedented capabilities to feed
back to companies to say I don't like
what you do to demand that they be more
socially responsible and all kinds of
things so I agree that one thinks it's
been interesting to watch as because
people have gotten more familiar with
technology because of facebook because
of Twitter because of ways because of
uber and then they go to their doctor's
office and it feels like it's kind of a
third world or they go to their kids
school and it feels like the things
haven't changed don't you know the kind
of way that's going to put more pressure
on these industries to figure out how to
invent new things and it's part of the
consumer it's partly technological
possibility but also consumers pushing
it but a key theme of this book it ties
in with your work with tech on me is it
not just about the software not just
about the engineering you need strategic
partners to be successful in third way
they need to engage with governments on
policy and technology has been a leader
in creating that forum where the
technologists can get together with the
policymakers and we need more of that
kind of discussion in the third way
because these are complicated issues
there they're regulating rate most of
these industries are regulated so you
can't just focus on the software you
can't just focus on the app you have to
focus on on partnerships within that
industry and engagement on policy with
government let's drag in France in the
car from London Francine yeah David to
your point the fact that we haven't
really harnessed I guess the full power
of facebook or other companies like that
how can a central bank how can a
government use it better to understand
what we're looking at we still have a
huge productivity public puzzle here in
the UK
I mean the poles are ridiculous we
didn't even foresee a Tory wink and
Facebook help with a simple stuff like
that well I think I'd love to your
Steve's thoughts on this but in fact
it's a great point that we have all this
data about the economy that's emerging
from a digitized connected landscape
that the government and the regulators
and the financial regulators are not
really tapping into in order to have a
much clearer real-time view of what's
happening in the economy I think they
make a lot of mistakes as a result do
you agree with that steam yeah I
actually think there's too much focus on
on regulatory issues around financial
services this issue of too big to fail
to the banks be broken up I actually
think and I wrote an op-ed in the Wall
Street Journal this week that the real
place to focus are these big banks too
too big to innovate because these fin
text article are doing it is so what's
to rallies around there what they're
going to be undone not by regulations
are going to be undone by startups
attacking every part of their friendship
Moynihan or diamond are gonna read your
book what's your prescription for James
diamond to keep the fortress diamond
momentum going he's got lean into the
future focus on what's happening next
position the company with what you're
doing already internally but then build
a network around your company figure out
a way to understand what the
entrepreneur doing figure out how to
partner with startups investments
through I you and why response and taxi
with my we are investigating another
number of different companies and
including some that are focused on the
lending platforms including we're
looking a lot of ways to reach out to
the unbanked the big banks don't really
serve them that it's payday lenders kind
of ripping them off and we're trying to
figure out new products and services
that untapped